Apple is diving headfirst into the
streaming wars with a new slate of
original programming that sounds great
but what does it all mean from the shows
you'll get to the price you'll pay for
it we've rounded up everything you need
to know about Apple TV plus let's talk
about Apple TV plus everyone clutching
their wallets can breathe a sigh of
relief Apple TV plus is going to be
among the most affordable of the major
streaming services launching at only
$4.99 per month this is less than half
the cost of Netflix's most popular plan
which is $12.99 per month or Hulu Zaid
free plan at $11.99 it's also less than
a third of the cost of the upcoming HBO
Mac's which is likely to cost anywhere
from 15 to 18 dollars per month or
comparable to the price point of Apple
TV plus or CBS all access at $5.99 per
month who lose $5.99 ad-supported plan
and Disney Plus which will cost $6.99
per month when it launches in November
however for early birds who jumped on
Disney's special offer and paid up front
in August of 2019 they'll have gotten
the best bargain of all snagging Disney
Plus for three years for less than $4
per month it's a commitment but a cheap
commitment right now Apple TV Plus can't
compete with that not unless they also
decide to roll out a similar discount
designed to tie subscribers to their
service for a few years just a little
over seven months after the tech company
first announced their new streaming
service Apple TV plus will hit screens
beginning on November 1st 2019 the app
will launch simultaneously in over 100
countries and regions meaning that no
matter where you're located there's a
pretty good chance you'll be able to
access the surface before the end of the
year this is a significantly larger
reach than Disney Plus which launches
two weeks later in only three countries
Disney has said they expect their
streaming service to be available in all
major markets within two years which
means it will likely take them a while
to catch up to Apple's substantial lead
however the scope of both services pales
in comparison to Netflix which is
already available in more than 190
countries and is probably their most
formidable competition
unlike other streaming services such as
Netflix Hulu and Disney Plus which
stream their own original movies and TV
series alongside an expansive catalog of
licensed and archival content Apple TV
intends to launch with an all-original
slate of movies and shows Apple has
reportedly spent upwards of 6 billion
dollars on their original content which
includes a number of new shows starring
some of the biggest names in Hollywood
so far we know of 9 confirmed titles
that will be available upon the services
launched on November 1st 2019 although
more are likely on the way these include
the morning show a behind the scenes TV
drama starring Jennifer Aniston Reese
Witherspoon and Steve Carell see a
speculative sci-fi series starring Jason
Momoa and Dickinson a comedic take on
the life of poet Emily Dickinson
starring Hailee Steinfeld also at launch
Apple TV plus will boast the new series
Ghost Rider help stirs for all mankind
and an original show from Oprah focusing
on the topic of mental health dozens of
other shows are also in various stages
of production with release dates still
to be announced Laura Mars Saturn stars
the galaxy while Apple TV plus will be
launching with a number of original
series and the company has said that
future films will be a significant part
of its offering going forward only two
feature-length originals have been
announced to be available at launch one
is the documentary the elephant Queen
which is narrated by Chua tell Ejiofor
and follows a mother elephant and her
herd under search for a new watering
hole the other is Snoopy in space an
animated film focusing on the Peanuts
characters otherwise apple has announced
only one feature film in the works on
the rocks starring Bill Murray and
rashida Jones and directed by Sofia
Coppola which will follow a young mother
as she attempts to reconnect to her
wealthy father despite the slim pickings
at launch Apple does intend to build a
robust slate of original films to stream
alongside its original series in
November of 2018 the company announced
its partnership with film studio a24
which will produce multiple films that
will play on Apple TV plus a 24s past
films include numerous Oscar winners and
nominees including Lady Bird ex machina
and moonlight
their deal with Apple seems to indicate
that not only will the tech giant be
taking its film slate seriously but that
it will also be in going for some major
awards although Apple TV plusses $5
price point is about as affordable as
streaming service subscriptions come
there is a way to get your subscription
for even less money month to month
although it requires a hefty upfront
cost starting on September 10th 2019
Apple began including a free gear long
subscription to Apple TV plus with the
purchase of any new or refurbished
iPhone iPad Apple TV iPod Touch or Mac
Plus through the use of family sharing
up to five more of your family members
can also access the service using your
free subscription however free in this
case is only from a certain point of
view while it's true that your bank
account won't be charged for $4.99 per
month fee for Apple TV plus if you
purchase a new Apple device you're still
at the cost of the device so as tempting
as the idea of a free year-long
subscription might seem it's probably
only a good deal if you were already in
the market for a new Apple device anyway
once Apple TV plus launches there will
be a number of convenient ways for you
to access the service assuming that is
you're already an Apple customer the
Apple TV app comes pre-installed on
iPhone iPad Apple TV and iPod Touch in
order to play Apple TV plus content your
device will likely need to be running a
recent version of Apple software meaning
you'll need to have updated to iOS 12.3
or later TV OS 12.3 or later or Mac OS
catallena you'll also be able to access
the Apple TV app through some Samsung
Smart TVs and in the future you can
expect to see the app show up on Amazon
fire TV LG Roku Sony and Vizio platforms
however if you don't own an Apple device
or supported Samsung TV and if you're
not in the market to upgrade your
devices to a supported model in the near
future your only option for watching
Apple TV plus content will be through
your web browser at TV Apple comm where
you can sign up for the service and
stream content
unlike Disney Plus which supports a
wider variety of devices Apple has
announced no plans to make their app
available on chromecast PlayStation and
Xbox or Android devices
what happened to your TV we had a
disagreement although most of the shows
and movies currently announced for Apple
TV plus will be in English the service
will have a number of options available
to make its content more accessible for
subscribers who speak other languages or
are hard of hearing at launch Apple TV
Plus content will be subtitled or dubbed
in nearly 40 different languages
including subtitles for the deaf and
hard-of-hearing and closed captions
additionally all of the content
available on Apple TV Plus will be
available with audio descriptions in 8
languages in order to activate a show or
film success ability features and change
your audio options you'll simply go to
the titles information page in the
iTunes Store or Apple TV app and scroll
to either the languages or accessibility
section depending on which functionality
you need for information on how to
enable subtitles or audio descriptions
in your Apple TV app is available on
Apple's web site often times it can be
convenient to be able to download a show
or film from a streaming service to
watch offline maybe you're traveling or
heading to a place with limited internet
access or maybe your internet connection
is glitchy and you want to ensure you'll
be able to watch your selection without
worrying that it will start freezing or
skipping
fortunately Apple has confirmed that
Apple TV plus will include a download
option for its original content giving
you the freedom to save a title to your
device to watch at your convenience no
matter where you are what's less queer
is exactly what sorts of restrictions
Apple will be placing on downloads it's
likely that the service may place limits
on how many shows you can download at
one time or on how many times you can
download the same show it also may
restrict your ability to download the
same show or film on multiple devices at
once and download options may vary
depending on your subscription option
and what sort of device you're using
it's almost hard to remember a time when
streaming services didn't grant us
access to entire seasons of television
series all at once
Netflix popularized the full season
bench model which is also how Amazon
Prime releases their series other
services such as Hulu and the upcoming
Disney Plus though go against that trend
by sticking to a one new episode per
week scheduled now every time a new
streaming service is announced one of
the first questions potential
subscribers ask is
other it shows will be released all at
once or one episode at a time Apple TV
plus will actually be taking a bit of a
hybrid approach to their release
schedule marrying binge and weekly
release models together for a format
that allows viewers to binge just enough
to get hooked on a series but then
requires them to exercise patience for
the rest while some series will have
their full seasons become available all
at once
most Apple TV Plus shows will premiere
with three episodes and then move to a
one a week schedule so if you want to
binge an entire series of an Apple TV
plus show in one sitting you're out of
luck unless you're willing to wait until
after the full season has aired unlike
other streaming services such as Netflix
Hulu Amazon Prime and CBS all access or
upcoming services such as Disney Plus
and HBO Macs Apple TV Plus is unique in
its approach to its streaming library in
that it won't include any licensed
content at all basically what this means
is that you shouldn't expect to see any
old favorites show up on Apple TV plus
their entire streaming library will be
made up of originals that haven't ever
previously aired anywhere else and which
you won't be able to find on any other
streaming service everything you watch
on Apple TV Plus can only be watched on
Apple TV Plus and won't include anything
you've ever seen before
this explains apple's staggering six
billion dollar investment in original
content for Apple TV plus since it will
be the only streaming service with an
entirely original slate of shows and
films it makes sense that the company is
sinking a significant amount of money
into making sure they produce a wide
variety of high-quality content that
will keep viewers engaged however it's
worth noting that Apple's budget still
doesn't come close to the money Netflix
spends on original content which is
expected to hit fifteen billion dollars
by the end of 2019 for individuals
curious about Apple TV plus who don't
necessarily want to commit to the $4.99
per month subscription cost and don't
want to purchase a new device in order
to receive a free subscription you're
still kind of in luck Apple TV Plus will
be offering a free 7-day trial for
customers new to the service starting at
launch on November 1st the free trial
will give subscribers access to all of
the services features and will be
available across all of their devices
just like the paid service
the end of the seven days your Apple TV
plus subscription will automatically
renew at the $4.99 per month rate which
will then continue to renew monthly
until you cancel the service in order to
avoid being charged after your trial
you'll need to make sure to cancel the
subscription before your seven days are
complete but of course by then Apple is
hoping you'll be hooked on the streaming
service and will gladly shell out your
hard-earned $5 per month in order to
keep watching check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]